We've discussed transnational capital,
the British Empire. We've also discussed
the Sabatine Frankets. Today we will put
the two ideas together
and show how the alliance between these
two different forces have created
modernity or the ideas
that underpin our society today
including Marxism, Darwinism,
individualism, liberalism and Freudian
psychology.
All right. So, we will talk a lot about
Jews today, but just as a caveat, it's
important for us to remember that it's
easy to see a Jewish conspiracy
everywhere.
But things are actually much more
complicated than that. The argument I
want to make you to you today is that
the Jews are construct and tool of
empire. In other words, they're really
the middle managers. to the ones who
helped manage the empire. And if the
Jews weren't around, then it would be
the Indians or some other group. An
empire needs scapegoats. It needs middle
managers. And for the past few years,
the Jews have served the purpose.
Something else I will show you today is
that the empire, which is transnational
capital, they all the profit. They hide
behind the scenes. They're the shadows
and they make all the money. And it's
really the Jews get all the blame. And
what we'll discuss next class is that
this is the same thing that will happen
today. Okay. So that's the argument I
will make to you today. All right. So
let's discuss the British Empire. The
British Empire is unique in human
history in that it controls the entire
world. Um and it's just a small island,
right? It's a small island with very
little resources and it's able to
control the entire world because it
controls global trade. It has the
world's greatest navy. It also it also
has a bank of England which is really
transnational capital
and English becomes the uh lingua frana
of the world and has colonies throughout
the world as well. So for the British
Empire the way they control the world
it's a very simple concept. As long as
the British Empire is able to control
the seaways,
then it controls the world. The great
crisis, the great problem, great threat
is that a empire will emerge within the
Eurasian continent. It's called the
heartland. Okay? And this could be
Germany, it could be Russia, it could be
China. But if it's able to emerge
eventually like the mong like the Mongol
Empire, it's able to conquer the entire
Eurasian continent and through railways
it's able to link up Africa, the Middle
East, Europe and Asia all together into
one trading block and then you don't
need the seaways anymore. If that were
to happen then the British Empire would
go bankrupt because remember the British
Empire with the Bank of England
transational capital it's really a Ponzi
scheme. It be it needs people to keep on
buying into the empire for it to
continue to succeed. So the greatest
threat is a great power emerging the
heartland and throughout history that
was either the French, the Ottoman
Empire, the Germans or the Russians. So
the grand strategy of the British is to
create as much chaos and conflict
in Europe as much as possible. You
always want your enemies fight each
other. Okay. And that's just the core
strategy of the British. Not very hard.
Okay.
Um so again as we discussed there are
four major enemies that the British have
faced throughout their uh uh history as
an empire. The French they able to
defeat because of the French Revolution
as well as the Nepolic wars. Uh then
they had to face the Russians and the
Russians were the greatest threat
because the Russians had the largest
land empire and they were the most
likely to unify the Asian continent. uh
they also face the Ottomans and they
also face the Germans. Now the British
could not
um
seem as though they were interfering in
European politics because that all that
would do is anger the Europeans and
youite the Europeans against the
British. They had to do it using sub
foods secretly using intelligence
operatives, right? And so of course what
happened was that
um they develop different strategies in
order to divide and conquer Europe. Uh
what they would do is promote
revolutionary movements
um using transnational capital and we'll
discuss these revolution movements later
on. They also industrialize Japan
because they saw Japan as a natural ally
in u in the world. Okay. So you know
that in Japan they underwent the Maji
restoration and in only a few decades
they were able to industrialize so much
so that they defeated Russia in the
RussoJapanese war in 1905
and you may not know this but capital
the British and Americans finance a
great deal of Japan's industrialization
because Anglo-American Empire wanted
Japan as an ally. Okay, it was a natural
ally. Um what they would also do is
establish resource colonies. So
Australia, New Zealand, Canada, these
South Africa, these are all resource
colonies. The idea is that you can now
use manpower to fund your armies. Okay.
And uh the last strategy is to wherever
you can steal as much resources as
possible as fast as you can. And this
was true in India and China and Africa
as well. Okay. So this is the grand
strategy of the British. and they needed
agents to help them in these endeavors.
And the 17 Frankas made the most sense,
right? Um so the advantages that 17 fra
empire were four-fold. The first is that
they already had a diaspora, right? And
so and they were also um crypto Jews.
They also disguise identity as Jews as
well. So they were able as a network to
conduct intelligence, do blackmail and
subvert governments. Okay. They also had
access to a lot of transnational
capital. They themselves were extremely
wealthy. The last uh major advantage and
the most important is that they had
revolutionary cells and networks. Okay.
So remember Frankus they believe that
they were saving the world. They
believed they had to destroy the world
in order to save it. And these made
perfect revolutionaries. And I'll show
you this as we move on. Okay. Now, the
last reason that we won't discuss much
today, but we'll focus a lot on in our
last class is the idea of esquetology
where the rich empire they are um
Christians and they believe that they
must use Jews as as a pawn in order to
force the return of Jesus. This we'll
discuss a great deal next class, but I
want I want to focus on these three
reasons first. Okay. All right.
Um, so and it made sense for the British
to align themselves with the 17 Frankus
because the way they saw the world was
the same. Okay. As an empire, as
transnational capital, remember, you're
focused on extracting as much energy as
possible from your workers. So, you're
very materialistic. Well, the Franks
were also very materialistic as well,
right? They believe that the body was
more important than the spirit. Second
is that the both the Frankus and the
British they wanted to obtain power
through chaos, instability and regime
change and both were very focused on the
pursuit of wealth and power. So these
were natural allies.
Sorry.
All right. So let's use an example of
how the Art Empire sorry. Let's use an
example of how the British Empire worked
this afternoon. And the most obvious
example is the Ottoman Empire. So for
the longest time the Ottoman Empire was
the most powerful force in in Eurasia.
And [snorts] this was the Ottoman Empire
at its height in 1683. Remember 1666 is
when somebody Zevi declared himself the
Messiah. And remember that Zeb Zevi have
to convert to Islam and the people who
follow him into Islam are called the
Dome. Okay, the Dome are very important
people.
Um, but over time empires will decay. In
1853, Russia attacked the Art Oman
Empire and this led to the Crimean War.
The British and the French feared
Russian expansionism and so they support
the Ottomans and uh the Ottomans were
able to defend themselves against the
Russians. But this alliance came at a
cost to the Ottomans. The British and
the French made the Ottomans seek out
loans in order to finance the war. And
over time because of interest they loan
these loans start to overwhelm the
Ottoman financial system. And so what
happened was the British and the French
bankers came and established their own
tax administration. And so from now on,
a third of all revenue, tax revenue that
the Ottoman Empire generated would go
directly to the French and British
bankers. Okay? And so this caused the
Ottoman Empire to decline rapidly over
time.
And uh the French and the British, they
set a central bank controlled by
foreigners. And not only that, but they
set their own tax administration.
So they they had their own tax agents
and that's why these bankers became very
wealthy. Guess what? These bankers had a
natural ally in a domain, right? The
Sabine Frankus.
Um, and so these Sabine Franks also
became very wealthy. Now, what happened
is that the Ottoman Sultan didn't really
like this relationship. He didn't like
being bossed around by these bankers.
And so, he went to the Germans. And so,
now the Germans were now financing
Ottoman Empire. And they were now
allies. And so, the British and the
French didn't like this. And so what the
do was start to finance a revolutionary
group called the young Turks. The young
Turks believed in three things. They
believed in secularism, no religion.
They believed in liberalism and they
believed in individualism. Okay, just
basically basic ideas of modernity.
[snorts]
And eventually the young Turks were able
to overwhelm the Ottoman Empire and
establish something called the Republic
of Turkey which is still around today.
So guys, the the we talk with Turkey. If
you go to Turkey, it's a do that control
Turkey. Okay.
All right. Um, so remember the do come
from Zabai Zevi.
They are cryptojews. They pretend to be
Muslim, but they're in fact Jews.
And these three do uh will help to found
the Republic of Turkey. And they still
control Turkey. Together. Okay, so
that's an example of an alliance between
the 17 something fraus and the British
Empire. Another example of an alliance
is of course the Rothschild banking
dynasty. This is Jacob Rothschild with
King Charles of England. And this
alliance goes back hundreds of years.
And um the Rothschild family
um is of course one of the most powerful
banking families in the world. So
there's a story of how they got rich. In
um 1815
Napoleon and the British fought the
battle of Waterloo and this would
determine who controlled Europe.
the in the battle, the British and the
Germans together were able to defeat the
French.
When this news happened,
an agent of the Rothschild got into a
Corvette, which is a fast boat, and they
sailed all the way back to London to
tell the Rothschild the news. The
Rothschild controlled the media at that
point. And so the the media told
everyone, "Oh my god, we lost the battle
of Wateroo." So, as you can imagine,
people start to panic. There was a stock
market crash. and then the Rothschild
bought up all the assets. That's how
they became extremely wealthy. And this
is a strategy that they continue to use
throughout their history. Okay. So, um
where the 17 Frank is and where the
British Empire clamped the most was in
philosophy, developing a understanding
the world that allowed them to amass
more power. Okay. So, let's go over
quickly over some basic British
philosophy. So British philosophy at
this time was controlled by Freemasons.
We'll discuss the Freemasons more next
class. Okay. But the main purpose was to
really deny God and truth and there were
three major strands of this philosophy.
Okay. The first major strand is what
called empirism and the most famous
proponent of this is John Lock. John
argue that we are born with a tablo rasa
a blank mind okay a blank slate and so
whatever information comes into us is
through experience only through
experience okay not through reasoning
not not because of god not because of
imagination or inspiration not because
of divine spark in us but through just
experience and only experience okay
David Hume proposed a new idea called
skepticism and he goes even further than
John lock John lock says that We
experience the world and that's how we
know the world.
Now the entire basis of science is the
idea called induction. If I see a white
swan a thousand times, I can then infer
that all swans are white. Okay, this
idea of induction, this is what
underlies process. Well, the idea of
induction, you can never access truth.
And what David Hume says is induction
does not work. You cannot prove that
just because you've never seen a black
swan, black swans don't exist.
Okay? You could have seen 10 million
white swans does not prove that all
swans are white and can only be white.
And he's right because there are black
swans. Okay? So what what he's saying is
the very project of truth seeeking, the
very project of epistemmonology of
philosophy, it's all nonsense. Not only
that, but we don't really know things.
All we do is remember things.
Okay? So when we say that Rome is a
capital of Italy, we think we know it,
but we don't we don't know it. It's all
just convention. It's all just we agree
to call a place in Italy Rome. We agree
that that's a capital. Okay, it's all
disagreement. But there's no basis for
truth here.
All right. So now this this raises the
problem of okay, if God doesn't exist,
if truth doesn't exist, if there's no
way for us to reach truth, if there's if
there's no way for us to discover truth,
then what can we do? And so uh Jerry
Bentham proposed the idea of
utilitarianism. The way we understand
the world is just through utility. If it
is good for the majority of people, then
it must be good. If it causes pleasure
for the majority of people, then that
policy must be good. If people want to
eat candy all the time and makes them
feel happy, then we should allow them to
eat candy and that is inherently good.
Okay? And then what his disciple
John Su Mill will do is he'll take the
basis of this idea of utility as a as a
basis of good and evil to create
liberalism. Okay. So the very idea of
liberalism today is based on
utilitarianism. So for example
homosexuality. Why is homosexually
homosexuality good? Because first of all
homosexuals want to be homosexuals.
Okay? You force them not to be
homosexuals they'll feel bad. But also
what's more important is they're not
doing any harm to anyone, right? So if
you just do the mathematics and you
recognize that allowing homosexuality is
a is a positive and that positive and
brings more pleasure to the world, then
you should allow it. Okay? And this
religious talk of it goes against the
will of God, it's against the Bible,
it's just it's just nonsense. We should
just focus on first principles
and just focus on utility. Does it bring
benefit to people? And this is the very
basis of
um British British British philosophy.
And as you can as you can appreciate
this align very much with the 17 Frank's
idea of the world, right?
All right. So this is John Mill and this
is Jeremy Banam. Okay. And not only
that, but once this philosophy is in
place, they are now going to promote
certain scientists
that um
um agree with this philosophy or or
whose findings support this philosophy.
And the most famous of course is Charles
Darin.
Okay, Charles Darwin, right? When his
book origin species came out, it was an
instant bestseller. And within 20 years,
it became the mainstream understanding
of how we originated. Even though you
actually read the book, even though you
actually look at science, it's still
very problematic. All right. So, this is
very strange how science is supposed to
be a field of rigorous debate, rigorous
science, right? But but the but the
evidence supporting evolution is limited
and again we discuss this all the time
but it doesn't explain to us how we come
to think right it explains to us how we
got our bodies sure yeah from apes we
get humans that makes sense but
intellectually we're a lot more
imaginative than apes how to explain
that and he doesn't explain that okay
and you're not even allowed to ask this
question
all All right. So,
um, as this alliance between the seven
Franks and the British Empire is
growing, there are certain individuals
that become
um these meeting points of these two
different groups. Okay. So, so let's
discuss two of them. The first is
Benjamin Deseli. And he's important
because he becomes the first and only
Jewish prime minister of the British
Empire. Okay. My second person is Leon
the Rothschild who is here to the
Rothschild begging family. They're best
friends and you can argue the Rothschild
begging family finance uh Benjamin
Draeli's uh banking career. Okay. And um
in 1844
Benjamin Desi will publish a book called
Conan Conins. It's a novel. Okay. It's
not a memoir but it's a novel. But if
you read it, people will say that the
characters are very much based on people
that this Israeli knows. And this really
is very explicit
in telling us why he wrote the book. And
the idea is to tell the British people
more about Jews because Jews right now
in history in Britain, they're an exotic
species. And it's also to establish how
Jews think. Now, what's amazing about
this um novel is that you read it and
it's really strange, but it conforms to
every single anti-semitic stereotype
that we say today. Today, you say that
Jews rule the world. You say that Jews
work together, they conspire together,
you say that Jews think that they're
superior to everyone else, you are
labeled as an anti-semit. Okay? But if
you read this novel and we'll read this
down together, this is exactly what bed
Israeli says, okay, about the Jewish
people. All right, so uh let's let's
read it together. Okay, so Emmer, can
you can you read please? This is the
introduction to
uh the book Connor speak. Okay,
>> in asserting the paramount character of
the
>> eistle
keep going. Okay.
Uh polity and the ma majesty of the
theocratic principle. It became
necessary to ascend to the origin of the
Christian church and to meet in a spirit
worthy of a critical and comparatively
enlightened age. The position of the
descendants of that race who were the
founders of Christianity. The modern
Jews had long labored under the odium
and stigma of medieval
meal.
What we're saying is this um
Christianity is a great religion but
it's important that we look at the
origins
of Christianity and who found
Christianity okay which is a Jews we
know we know it's a Jews who create
Christianity okay keep on going
>> in the dark ages when history was
unknown the passions of societies
undisturbed by tra tradition
[sighs and gasps]
traditionary experience were strong and
their convictions um mitigated by
criticism were necessarily fanatical
So during the dark ages, everyone was
just stupid. Okay, keep on going.
[laughter]
>> The Jews were looked upon in the Middle
Ages as an a cursed race, the enemies of
God and man, the special foes of
Christianity. No one in those days
paused to reflect that Christianity was
founded by the Jews, that its divine
author in his human capacity was a
descendant of King David.
>> Wait, divine author of course is Jesus.
Okay.
>> That his doctrines a vowedly were the
completion
not the change of Judaism. That the
apostles and the evangelists who names
men daily invoked and whose volumes they
embraced with reverence were all Jews.
That the infallible throne of Rome
itself was established by a Jew. And
that a Jew was the founder of the
Christian churches of Asia. So this
really is not just saying that Jews are
important, but he's also saying that
Jews are superior because they're the
ones who created Christianity. And what
what he will say later on is Jews
created everything because Jews are the
most intellectually creative people in
the world. Okay. And remember, this
really is a Jew and he's one of the
Jewish elite. Okay. All right. Let's
keep on going. All right. So in the
novel, the major character is Adidonia,
who is a wealthy Jewish person based on
the Rothschild family. Okay. And he's
going to explain to us how Jews control
the world. All right. Can you read Alan?
>> Yeah. Okay.
>> Sedonia.
>> Sedonia was descended from a very Asian
and noble family of arrogant.
>> Okay. Aragon is in Spain. Okay. So we
discussed how before 100 years the Jews
were part of uh the Spanish Muslim
Empire but when they were reconquered
they were forced to leave or convert
going that in the course of ages had had
given to the state many distinguished
citizens in the priesthood its member
had been precar precoliately eminent
besides several prelades they counted
among their numbers and ar
Arkbishop of Toato and Sidonia in a
season of great danger and different
diff different difficulty difficulty had
exercised for a series of years the
paramount office of grand inquisitor.
Okay. So even after the Christians
reconquered Spain and after some Jews
converted to Catholism. Okay. First of
all these Jews kept their faith secret.
So even though on the outside they were
Catholics, in the inside they were still
Jews. Okay, they were crypto Jews. But
much more importantly, these Jews rose
to supreme power within the Catholic
Church in
Spain. The irony is that the Spanish the
Spanish Inquisition where Catholics were
looking for Jews who were pretending to
be Christians, the leadership were Jews.
The leadership were crypto Jews. Okay,
this is this is what this really saying.
I'm not saying this is true, but this is
what this really is saying. Okay, uh
keep on going. Yet strange at it may
sound, it is nevertheless a fact of
which there is no lack of evidence that
these ill illustrious family during all
these period in common with twoird of
the
uh aren arang
uh nobility secretly adhered to the
Asian faith and ceremonies of their
fathers. I believe in the unity of the
god of senior seni and the rights and
observances of the laws of Moses.
>> Okay. So guys, 23 of nobility in Spain
were crypto Jews. Catholics disgu uh
Jews disguised as Catholics. Okay. All
right. So again, I'm not saying this is
true, but it's striking and really
strange that a Jewish man who's very
powerful will become prime minister of
England. He's writing this stuff. Okay.
He's putting the mouth in the put in the
mouth of basically a rash child.
Okay. Uh can you read Amber?
>> The Sedonius of Aragon were
>> new Christians
>> were nuvo Christianos Christristenos.
Some of them no doubt were burned alive
at the end of the 15th century under the
system of to Quimada. Many of them
doubtless were the San Bonito, but they
kept their titles and estates and in
time reached those great office uh
offices to which we have referred.
During the long disorders of the
peninsula war when so many openings were
offered to talent and so many
opportunities seized by the adventurous
ait of younger branch of this family
made a large fortune by military
contracts and supplying the comat
commisserate of the different armies at
the peace precient of the great
financial future of Europe.
confident in the fertility of his own
gen genius in his original views of
fiscal subjects and his knowledge of
national resources. Then Sedonia feeling
that Madrid Madrid or even Katis could
never be a base on which the monetary
transactions of the world could be
regulated resolved to immigrate to
England with with which he had in the
course of years formed considerable
commercial connections. He arrived here
after the peace of Paris with his large
capital. He staked all he was worth on
the waterl loan and the event made him
one of the greatest capitalists in
Europe.
>> Okay. So these crypto Jews they had a
lot of money but not only that but they
have a lot they have an information
network okay because they have relatives
friends all throughout Europe and there
are index to superior and so they know
how history will develop and they see a
great money making opportunity in war.
So when these wars come out, what these
Jews do is they support both sides. So
they have possibly lose and then they
make a lot of money and then they figure
out where it is in their most advantage
to be. So they have actually no national
loyalty. Don't see themselves as
belonging to a certain group of people,
a certain nation. They see themselves as
first and foremost Jews. Okay? So when
the time presented itself properly,
these Sedonians they will migrate, some
of them, not all of them will migrate
from Spain into continental Europe and
up to England because they saw England
as a future. And of course from England
they will also migrate to the United
States of America. Okay.
Um Alan, can you read please?
>> The only human quality.
>> Sorry. So the the the father goes to
England and now he establishes the
banking dynasty and his son will now
inherit everything. Okay. And and so and
so this is about the sun. Keep on going.
>> Yeah. The only human quality that
interested Sidon Sidonia was in
intellect her he cared not whence it
came where it was to be found. Creed
country class character in this respect
were alike indifferent to him.
>> Okay. So again this is a very
anti-semitic trope where Jews don't like
the idea of nation or culture or
religion. They like the idea of ideas.
Okay. And one anti-semitic trope is that
Jews have a conspiracy to degrade
religion
uh culture society nation state in order
to advance their own interests. Okay.
The author, the artist, the man of
science never appealed to him in vain.
Often he anticipate their wrongs and
wishes. He encouraged their society was
as frank in his conversation as he was
generous in his contributions. But the
instant they ceased to be authors,
artists or philosophers, and their
communications arose from anything but
the intellectual quality which had
originally interest him. The moment they
were rash enough to approach intim in
intimacy and appeal to the sympathizing
men instead of the congenial
intelligence, he saw them no more. Okay,
so this is a really important idea where
again this is propaganda for Jews,
right? So this really is saying how
great Jews are. Jews are intellectual.
But you know what Hegel, Frederick Hegel
will say is that without culture there
can be no great ideas.
Okay, ideas emerge from community, from
culture, from belonging. Okay, so think
of uh Homer or Dante or even the Yahweh.
Okay, if you if you think that you are
intellectual above culture, above
nation, above people, you will not
produce great ideas. Okay, keep on
going. It was not however intellect
merily in these unquestionable shapes
that commanded his notice. There was not
an adventurer in Europe with whom he was
not familiar. No minister of state has
such communication which secret agents
and political spies as Sidonia. He held
relations with all the clever outcasts
of the world. The cat catalog of his
acquaintance in the shape of Greeks am
Marinians Moors secret Jews tartans
geese geese seeds.
>> Okay. All right. That's fine. Okay.
Look, the idea is that Jews are intern
first and foremost international the
cosmopolitan
right and as a result what will happen
is that over time because he is in
contact with so many different groups
he's so intellectual he's always reading
his his history he comes convinced that
the superior race the greatest race of
humanity are the Jews why because unlike
other races the Jews refuse refuse to
intermar. They refuse to breed with
other cultures. And so as so as a
result, the Jews are first and foremost
peer. They are Aryan. Okay, this is
really ironic again because the Nazis
will use this idea 100 years later to
justify the Holocaust. But at this time
in history, uh the Jews think that they
are the superior race because they are
the most pure. Okay. So So this is all
that is saying. [snorts]
All right. Can you read Amber?
>> In this country, says Adidonius.
>> So this country of course is England,
right?
>> Since the peace there has been an
attempt to advocate a reconstruction of
society on a purely rational basis. The
principle of utility has been powerfully
developed. I speak not with lightness of
the labors of the dis disciples of that
school. I bow to intellect in every form
and we should be grateful to any school
of philosophers even if we disagree with
them. Doubtly grateful in this country
were for so long a period of our state
statesmen were in so pit pitiable
and a career of public intelligence.
There has been attempt to reconstruct
society on a basis of material motives
and calculations.
>> Okay. So again this is the idea of
utitarianism right? This is Jimmy
Bentham, John Suit Mill. Keep on going.
>> It has failed. It must ultimately have
failed under any circumstances. Its
failure in an ancient and densely people
kingdom was inevitable. How limited is
human reason, the profoundest inquir
inquirers are most conscious. We are not
indebted to the reason of man for any of
the great achievements which are the
landmarks of human action and human
progress. It was not reason to be
besieged to Troy. It was not reason that
sent forth the sarin
from the desert to conquer the world.
>> Okay. So the Serakans are the Muslims.
Okay.
>> That inspired the crusades um that
instituted the monastic orders. It was
not reason that produced the Jesuit
Jesuits. Above above all, it was not
reason that created the French
Revolution. Men is only truly great when
he acts from the passion. Never
irresistible, but when he appe when he
appeals to the imagination. Even Mormons
counts more votaries than
>> Benam.
And you think then that an imagination
once subdued the state. Imagination may
now save it. Man is made to adore and to
obey. But if you will not command him,
if you give him nothing to worship, he
will fashion his own divinities and find
a
chieftain in his own passions.
>> So um Sono is is emphasizing the
limitations of British philosophy,
right? Law, hume, banan, they're all
limited. And so what the British need is
for the Jews with their imagination,
with their religion to save the British,
to lead the British, to guide the
British. Okay? Does that make sense?
So again, this is trying to establish
Jewish supremacy. Okay? All right. This
is much too long. Okay? But what he's
really saying is
like, listen, we Jews, we want to be
part of society. We are naturally
conservative but we also want to
practice our religion. So if you at any
point if you the British at any point
try to restrain us, if you try to take
away our religious rights, we will rebel
against you. We are cohesive. We we will
stand up for liberalism. We will stand
up for secularism. We will stand up for
individualism because these three
philosophies are what most protect us
from religious overreach. Okay? Does
that make sense? Okay. So that's that
that's what he's saying. So Alan, can
you start here? You never observe.
>> Yeah.
>> You [snorts] never observe a great
intellectual movement in Europe in which
the Jews do not greatly participate. The
first Jesuits were Jews.
>> This is true. Okay guys, the secret
intelligence agency of the Catholic
Church were first Jews. This is true.
Keep on going.
That mysterious
Russian diplomacy which so alarmed
Western Europe is organized and
principally carried on by Jews.
>> So the Jews are the agents of the
Russian Empire. Right. The mighty
revolution which is at th this moment
preparing in Germany and which will be
in fact a second and greater
reformations and of which so little is
at yet know in England is entirely
developing under the an uh
>> opaces
>> opaces of Jews who almost monopolize the
professional profession professorial
chairs of Germany.
>> Okay. So this doesn't happen yet. Okay.
He's saying this year 1844 he's saying
like the revolution you will see later
on in Germany we organized it man we
Jews organized it why because we control
themies we control the professorships of
Germany you want keep on reading
>> ner the founder of spiritual christ
Christianity
who and who is re regious professor of
divinity in the university of Berlin as
a Jew
>> okay so keep on going okay we won't read
it about how many professors are Jews
okay do you understand now what's
amazing is again this came out 1844 and
there were revolutions throughout Europe
throughout Germany. So how did the
Israeli know about this? Well, possibly
because the British were helping to
finance all this right from the alliance
between the British and the Frankus.
All right. Uh can you read Amber?
>> Okay. From
>> from from here. Okay.
>> A few years back we were applied to by
Russia. Now there has been no friendship
between the court of St. Petersburg and
my family. It has Dutch connections
which have generally supplied it and our
representations in favor of the Polish
Hebrews a numerous race but the most
suffering and degraded of all the tribes
have not been very agreeable to the
Cesar the SAR. Okay. So what he's saying
is we're very rich and nation states
come and look for us for money. Okay. So
Russia wants a loan from us. We said,
"No, you mistreat the the Jews, so we're
not going to give you any money." Okay.
The Russians are notorious for being
anti-semitic at this stage. Okay, keep
on going.
>> However, circumstances drew to an
approximation between the Romanoffs.
>> The Romanovs are the controlling family
of Russia
>> and the Sidonians. I resolved to go
myself to St. Petersburg. I had on my
arrival an interview with the Russian
minister of finance court
>> count.
I beheld the son of a lethusian Jew. The
loan was connected with the affairs of
Spain. I resolved on repairing repairing
to Spain from Russia. I traveled without
intermission. I had an audience
immediately on my arrival with the Spain
minister Senor Mendes Sabul. I beheld
one like myself, the son of a Novo
Cristiano, a Jew of Aragon. In
consequence of what transpired at
Madrid, I went straight to Paris to
consult the president of the French
Council. I beheld the son of a French
Jew, a hero, an imperial marshall, and
and very appropriately so. For who
should be military heroes, if not those
who worship the Lord of hosts? And is
salute a Hebrew? Yes. And others of the
French marshals. And the most famous,
Masenna, for example, his real name was
Manisa.
Manessa. But to my anecdote, the
consequence of our consult consultations
was that some northern powers should be
applied to in a friendly and mediative
capacity. We fixed on Prusia and
>> Prussia and the president of council
made an application to the Prussia
Prussian minister who attended a few
days after a conference. Count Arnim
entered the cabinet and I beheld a
Prussian Jew. So you see my dear
>> Connor speak Connor speak
>> Connor speak that the world is governed
by very different personage from what is
imagined by those who are not behind the
scenes.
>> So it's Jews who control the world
because only Jews get along together.
Okay. So if Jews didn't exist, the world
couldn't get along, right? And Jews hide
everywhere. And that's how the world
works, guys. You think the person in
charge is in charge, but actually it's a
secret society of of Jews. Now, again,
I'm not saying this is true. I just
found it really weird that Benjamin
Israeli is writing about this, okay? And
again, he's getting a lot of this
information from the Rothschild banking
family. So, the Rothschild, for whatever
reason, think they control the world.
Okay? So I don't go much into this in
detail, but I will point out that there
is evidence that this is true. All
right, so we're going to look at the
communist revolution in Russia together.
I also want to keep you in mind that I
don't think this is true. Actually,
there's evidence is true, but I do not
think this is true. Why this really is
writing about this, we will discuss next
class, okay? But it's all part of a
secret plan.
All right, but first let's look at the
evidence that this may be true. Again,
I'm not saying this is true, but there
is evidence that this is true. Okay? And
the main major piece of evidence is the
communist revolution, the bullsh
revolution 1917 that overthrew the uh
government of Russia to create a
communist government. All right, first
let's talk about revolution. There are
four elements you need in order for a
revolution to be successful. Okay, the
first is you need a really charismatic
leader. Second is you need a broad mass
appeal usually land for the peasants
freeing debt okay and end of war peace
then you need organizational discipline
everyone has to get along okay has to be
a cohesive group the last element of
course is you need incompetent
opposition your enemies a okay and
of course the classic example of this is
maong versus Changai. Okay. Minon was a
charismatic leader who had a very strong
organization and checked even though he
had a huge army even though he had the
American army. Even though he had all
sorts of benefits, he was a Okay.
And that's why he lost. [snorts]
All right. So the same is true for the
Russian Revolution. This is Valer Lenin.
He's not charismatic, but he is
extremely focused. He's fanatical.
And
um this is Leonki who is very
charismatic. He's a very he's a great
speaker and he's a Jew. Okay. So I will
point out that in 1917 he helped lead
the revolution. But before that he was
actually the United States.
He had an apartment in New York City
paid for by wealthy Jewish bankers. His
uncle is a very wealthy Jewish
industrialist in Ukraine. Okay. So, he's
part of this transnational capital
network and even though he himself is a
revolutionary, he hates capitalism. If
someone gives you money, you cannot help
but be influenced by that person. Okay?
That's just a reality.
[snorts]
All right? So um October 1917 is when
the bullshiks uh launched a revolution
and they seized power and then a month
later they organized um an election and
as you can see they are actually not
that they are not the most popular party
in Russia. Um they only have about 23%
of the votes. The socialist
revolutionaries actually have much more
popularity than they do. They have 37%.
And then you have all these different
groups. the Ukrainians, the cadets who
are liberals, dimensions,
um the Kosaks. So at this point in
history, Russia is divided into so many
different groups. You have different
ethnicities, you have different
political programs, you have um
different orientations. Okay? And this
is what will launch the great civil war.
Okay? And at this time in history,
remember the bullshiks only control a
certain part of Russia. They are the
official government, but they only
control a small part. and the white army
who are the which combination of the
liberals and monarchists they have much
more stronger military and also at the
same time you have all these different
ethnic groups the Ukrainians rebelling
against the boss including the Polish
but over the next 5 years slowly the
bull blevik will obtain absolute power
and so the question is how do they do
that well the first tool is
terror. Okay, this this is called the
red terror where they went around and
killed anyone who opposed them. Now,
what you don't understand is there's
actually a strategy behind the red
terror. The the very idea is to steal as
much money as possible from wealthy
people. Okay? So, you're an aristocrat.
You have a lot of wealth hidden. I need
your money. So you either give me your
money or I will kill your daughter and I
will kill your son and I will then I
will kill your wife. Okay? So it's your
choice. Give me all your money or I'll
kill everyone in your family. So the
Bullshiks were fanatical about this and
that's why they won the war. [snorts]
Leon Trosky organized the red army in um
the war against the white army. Okay.
They also the greens which were these
peasants. So there's a lot so the
Bushiks were far behind. So, how did the
Bullshiks, the Red Army, win the war?
Well,
guys, they had a lot of help. Okay, they
had a lot of mercenaries coming to the
country, tens of thousands of
mercenaries to help them, especially uh
the Chinese mercenaries, the Latvians,
the Hungrians. Okay, why? How did they
get all this money? Transnational
capital. Wall Street and City of London
were bankrolling the Soviets. Why were
they doing that? [snorts]
Also we have to remember that at this
time in history during the revolution
Britain and France, United States, Japan
sent armies into
Russia. Now what you learn in class is
oh it's because they are capitalists and
they fear the communists and that's why
they sent armies to try to uh uh reduce
the threat. That's not true
guys. Why is it the armies is because
the Bolsheviks
reigned on debt. Okay, Russia owed a lot
of money to Britain, Japan, United
States and France. And so these armies
were sent in order to threaten the
Bviks. So what the Bik Bixs did was they
stole as much money as they could from
the peasants, from nobility, from the
treasury and pay off these armies. And
then these armies helped them in the war
against the uh the whites. Okay. Does
that make sense? Okay.
All right. So, let's summarize what what
we've just learned. Now, what you're
taught in history class is American
Britain needs Russia in war against
Germany. And that's why and the Germans
control the Bolshviks. And that's why
Britain and uh America would not support
the bullshiks. And the counter argument
is no, it's transnational capital that
has influence over Anglo-American
foreign policy. Okay, do you understand?
Anglo-American foreign policy. It's not
to serve national interests. It's not
it's to serve private capital. Okay,
that's the first point. Second point is
the Bviks are communists and so they're
a threat to capitalism. And the kind
argument is actually transnational
capital cares about profit. They don't
care about ideology. All right. What
drives them is money not ideas. The
third argument is the most hated
imperialism and capitalism. So they
would refuse to work with Wall Street
and the city of London. And the kind of
argument of is that they believe that
the ends justify the means. We just have
to like do what we need in order to
obtain power. Then we can create our
socialist paradise. Okay. All right. All
right. So, uh, this is a book called
Wall Street and the Russian Revolution.
A story by Rich by the name of Richard
Spence. He spent a lot of time
collecting documents that show that in
fact transational capital were helping
the bullshiks
win power in Russia. Why? Because they
believed in the bullshiks? No. Because
transial capital first and foremost
steals. You understand? They like
revolution because revolution is
opportunity to steal as much as you can.
Okay. You can buy things really cheaply
during a revolution. And this this is
his argument. All right. So, let's read
a couple passages from his book. So, uh
Emma, can you read please?
>> The pro bosic fashion faction on Wall
Street had a most outspoken pitchmen in
the
>> aforementioned William Boyce Thompson.
Departing Petrograde, he arrived back in
the states on Christmas Day in 1917. On
18th January, he sat for an interview
with a representative of Do Jones and
published in the Wall Street Journal.
>> Wall Street Journal of course is the
newspaper of the of Wall Street. boy.
>> Despite the fact that Bolshvix uh had
proclaimed an army army on the Eastern
front and open peace negotiations with
Berlin, Thompson insisted that the
Russians would never conclude a separate
peace.
>> Okay, so he's just lying to people.
Okay, the Bikes want peace with Germany.
They promise peace to the people. That's
why they're popular. And these Wall
Street bankers are just lying to
American people. Okay, keep on going. He
pooed pooed reports that there was
anarchy in Russia and said that the
Russian people were trying to adopt
socialism as the basis of their
government. If they were allowed to
succeed, an extremely democratic,
well-managed country will emerge. In
other words, an excellent business
environment.
>> So, what the basically did was they took
all the gold they had to bribe Wall
Street so that Wall Street would go and
brainwash American people. Okay. That's
that's the strategy here.
>> All right. Um, can you read, Alan? Yeah,
>> for those on Wall Street and elsewhere
who dreamed of putting the brakes on
Russia's economic development and seeing
its reaches and resources up for grabs
under the regime willing to sell
anything that dreams had basically come
true.
>> Okay, so it's really important to
understand the British Empire was
fighting a war against Germany. Russia
was an important ally, right? They
didn't care because for Britain they
want to destroy everyone. Okay. So
that's why they support the Russian
revolution because they know they knew
the boss would destroy the Russian
economy.
So keep on going.
>> Yeah. From 1918 through early 1921, Bri
war commun communism reduced Russian to
an econ economic based on barter and
robbery. Besides the abolition of
private trade and the destruction of the
monetary system, the rare regime
embarked on a massive looting campaign,
reanking
rents palaces, bank vaults, churches,
and museums. They expropriate every
volume valuable they could get their
hands on and stash it all in a new state
treasury. By the close of 1921, an
estimate $450 million dollars in
valuable had been sequestered
u sequested sequested there with more to
come. Much of it does not disting to be
fenced abroad for a fraction of its
value in capital capitalist hard
currency.
>> So this is how empire works guys, okay?
They destroy nations in order to steal
as much as they can. What happens
afterwards? They don't care.
All right. It's that simple. All right.
Okay. So, after the Bolsheviks
consolidate power, after the win civil
war, everyone assumes that Trosky would
be the new leader. But it's Stalin that
becomes the new leader. Okay. Why?
Because after the war ends, there's
expectation among the bullshiks. know we
help the transational capital so much
they're going to help us rebuild our
nation. Okay, they're going to give us
loans. They will give us technology to
help us rebuild Russia. And guess what
happened? National Capital says, "No,
you guys are good. We're good. We we
made our money." Okay? And so now what's
happening is that Leontrosky, who is a
Jew, he gets blamed, right? Because
Leontrosky is the one who brought in
transational capital. He's the one who
facilitated this exchange. And now the
is thinking, "Oh, this is
Jewish conspiracy. You Jews were
planning this all along to steal
everything from us and then screw us
over in the end." Okay, that's why
Stalin won. All right, so let's go over
the difference between Leon Trosky and
Joseph Stalin. Leon Trosky did not work
for transnational capital. Okay, he was
first and foremost a revolutionary who
was interested in global revolution. He
had a he had a mess calling to transform
and save the world. Um but he was
accused of being transational capital
and because he was a Jew that just
assumed that he was a spy. Okay. And um
he also had a personality which was
arrogant and aloof. Stalin had his own
issues. Okay. But he benefited from the
fact that Trosky was a Jew and he was
able to slowly amass power for himself.
He also has a background as a police
informant but um but being a spy for the
capitalist was a much worse crime. All
right. And that's why Joseph Stalin uh
won in the end and this is terrible for
the Jews the BI Jews who believed in the
revolution because they all got killed
by Joseph Stalin. Okay. Leoni was killed
along with his with all his children.
[snorts]
All right. So it's not just that
transational capital supported the
bullshiks, they also supported Carl
Marx. Okay. All right. So Karl Marx has
an interesting background. He actually
comes from a uh many generations of
rabbis. So he's basically a Jewish
aristocrat and he was German, but then
he moved to England and he wrote many
letters, wrote many books to promote
communism. These books aren't going to
sell well. So he was poor all his life.
But what's interesting is he lived a
very nice life. Okay, he he lived in
England and he lived a basic middle
class life. So where did he get all his
money from? Well, he got he got all his
money from Frederick Engles who was a
friend of his and whose father was an
industrialist. Okay, a Jewish
industrialist. So why would a Jewish
capitalist support Carl Marx? And the
answer is because communism benefits
transnational capital. Okay. So um why
why would it benefit transational
capital? All right. Uh can can you read
Amber? So this is a letter written by
Carl Marx. Okay.
[snorts and clears throat]
>> For as soon as the distribution of labor
comes into being each man has a
particular exclusive sphere of activity
which is forced upon him and from which
he cannot escape. He is a hunter, a
fisherman, a herdsman or crit a critical
critic and must remain so if he does not
want to lose his means of livelihood.
While in communist society where nobody
has one exclusive sphere of activity but
each can become accomplished in any
branch he wishes, society regulates the
general production and thus makes it
possible for me to do one thing today
and another tomorrow to hunt in the
morning, fish in the afternoon, rare
cattle in the evening, criticize after
dinner and uh and as I have a mind
without ever becoming hunter, fisherman,
horsemen or critic. Okay. So the problem
with capitalism is that it degrades our
individuality.
We as individuals want freedom to enjoy
ourselves. Right? This is a very frankus
idea, right? We want to enjoy ourselves.
We want to be free to enjoy the
pleasures of life. The problem of
capitalism is the idea of
specialization,
right? Where you're forced to do one
thing, one thing only according to the
needs of the capitalist. Okay. Uh can
you keep on reading, Amber? Okay.
>> Supposing that we had produced in a
human manner in his production each of
us would have doubtly affirmed himself
and his fellow men. I would have
objectified in my production my
individuality and its peculiarity and
would thus have enjoyed in my activity
and individual expression of my life and
would have also had in looking at the
object the individual pleasure of
realizing that my personality was
subjective, visible to the senses and
therefore a power raised beyond all
doubt.
>> Okay. So what what he's saying here is
that before each of us were crafts
people. So I might make a vase. Okay.
And when I make a vase then this vase is
a expression of my individuality
expression of my creativity. And by
looking at this vase it becomes an
objective
symbol of my existence. I can look at
this vase and my own individual individ
individuality will be reflected back to
at me. Okay, keep on going.
>> In your enjoyment or use of my product,
I would have had the direct enjoyment of
realizing that by my work I had both
satisfied a human need and also
objectified the human essence and
therefore fashioned for another human
being the object that met his need.
>> Then I give you this vase to a friend
and I see this vase at the friend's
home, right? He puts flowers
and he's very happy with this vase and
then I I can see my impact in the world.
All right. Uh, keep on reading. Amber,
>> I would have been for you the mediator
between you and the species and thus
between and thus been felt by you and
acknowledged as a completion of your own
essence and a necessary part of yourself
and I would thereby have realized that I
was confirmed both in your thought and
in your love.
>> Okay. So this vase now shapes your
reality and I know that this vase has
given you meaning and it has shaped your
reality and therefore I find meaning in
that. Okay. Again this is a very
Frankish attitude right where you can
project your imagination onto people and
it can shape the way he or she sees
reality. Okay. This is a very similar
concept. Do you want
>> in my expression of my life I would have
fashioned your expression of your life
and thus in my own activity I have
realized my own essence my human
communal essence
>> okay right so again this is something
that sounds perfectly correct right and
the reason why it sounds correct to us
is because it becomes a basis for our
society
okay the idea of individ individualism
the idea of materialism
okay keep on going
>> in such a situation our products would
be like so many mirrors. Each one
reflecting on our essence thus in this
relationship what occurred on my side
would also occur on yours.
>> Okay, so this is a really important
metaphor. Okay, he's saying that objects
become mirrors where we can see our own
individuality reflected. Okay, and this
goes against the religious concept where
our humanity is all reflected in each of
us. Okay. So, so what he's doing is
creating a material outlook. Does that
make sense? He's denying the existence
of God. He's he's denying the existence
of spirituality, but he's taking the
concept of religion and applying to a
material world, right? He recognizes
that we have these spiritual religious
needs. And what he's saying is that we
don't need God to achieve these needs.
We can we can have materialism achieve
these needs. Okay? Which again is a very
Frankish concept. Keep on going. My work
would be a free expression of my life
and therefore a free enjoyment of my
life. In work, the peculiarity of my
individuality would have been affirmed
since it is my individual life. Work
would thus be genuine active property
presupposing private property and my my
individuality is so far externalized
that I hate my activity. It is a torment
to me and only the appearance of an
activity and thus also merely a force
activity that is laid upon me through an
external arbitrary need not an inner and
necessary one.
>> Right? So why would transnational
capital support this idea? The reason
why is that before the debate was mind
versus matter, right? What what matters
more the spirit or the flesh? And what
Marx is saying is no what matters what
the debate the dialectic is between
private property versus public property
in private property I have to work for
someone else in public property I work
for myself that's the question that's
the debate that's the dialectic okay and
so what by doing this it's a very clever
trick that trans capital uses by making
us think that the only thing that
matters is private versus public as
opposed to mind versus matter. Okay,
that's the goal of communism. That's why
trans capitalist support idea because it
advances the goal of empire which is
turn us all into slaves. Okay, does that
make sense? All right. [snorts]
All right. So Markx is correct in
analyzing the problems of capitalism.
Okay.
But his problem is that he believes the
solution is to make capital public
and as a result this will create a
workers's paradise.
But there are problems with this. Okay.
So let's go over some of the problems.
Okay. Markx believes that history is
linear progress. So capitalism will lead
to socialism which will lead to
communism. It is a linear progress.
Okay. Second is a problem that history
is theological, meaning things go the
way they should. Markx also believes
that what matters is class struggle
between the rich and the poor as opposed
to uh between spirit and flesh. Okay.
Now, the last thing that's that's most
problematic is Marx believes you need a
vanguard in order to lead the politarian
into a socialist paradise. you need an
elite in order to
um lead us into paradise. And this
estology is all Frankish, right? This is
something that we learned last class.
This is something that Frank proposed
where um his group is a new people which
will lead people into a material
paradise. Right? [snorts] So all Marx is
doing is
taking Jacob Frank's ideas and
systemizing it. Now I'm not saying that
Marx was a Frankus. He's probably not a
Frankus.
But what I'm saying is that there are
people around him like Frederick Engles
who could have been a Frankus and as
such and they used their money to
influence Marx in a way. Okay. And we kn
and I we can suspect this because
there's some ideas that don't make
sense. If you are a socialist, you
believe in democracy. But Marx believed
in a dictatorship.
Okay, that makes no sense. All right.
So,
um this is Muel Buchanan and he was a
socialist. He was an anarchist. And he
believes
uh he agrees with most of Mark's
analysis, but where they disagree is
this.
Markx believed you need a vanguard.
Okay? Like critical Frank believed. But
Bennon says, "No, no, no. If you're a
vanguard, they'll just become a new
capitalist class. Okay? What's the
difference, man? If you are a socialist,
you have to believe in democracy.
You have to believe that everyone has
capacity to make his or her decisions.
And that has that must be the basis of
your new society. Otherwise, we're just
going to go back to the way things are
before. Okay? It'll just it'll just be
another empire. Before it's a British
Empire, now it's a Russian Empire. Who
cares? What's the difference? All right.
So, let let's read some. Okay. All
right. Can you read Amber?
>> As for us, we want neither phantoms nor
nothingness, but living human reality.
And we recognize that man can feel free,
be free, and therefore can achieve
freedom. In order to be free, I need to
see myself surrounded by free men, and
be recognized as such by them. I am free
only when my individuality reflected in
the mirror of the equally free
consciousness of every individual around
me comes back to me strengthened by
everyone's recognition.
>> Okay,
>> so this is really important. Okay, this
may seem the same as Marks, but really
they're saying different things. Mark
says no, the object is a reflection. And
what we kind of say, no, no, no, the
other person is a reflection. Okay. And
this goes back to Dante Zorusra Jesus
the divine spark in us and we love
someone else. When we care about someone
else, our divine spark is reflected in
that person's divine spark as well.
Okay. And the object gets in the way.
That is a crucial distinction. Do you
understand? Okay. It sounds the same,
but these are two radically opposing
ideas where Mark says, "No, it's the
object that matters. As long as the
object is created by yourself freely
then that is good. And what we kind of
says no no what matters is our
relationship with each other. Okay we
don't need the object. Okay.
>> The freedom of every other individual
does not limit my own as the
individualists claim. On the contrary,
it is the confirmation, realization and
human dignity of all persons to see and
feel my freedom confirmed, sanctioned
and boundlessly expanded by universal
agreement is happiness. It is human
paradise on earth.
>> How you create paradise is through love.
Okay, you understand? Not through
objects, not through public property,
not through socialism, but through love.
Okay, the problem with Markx is he focus
on the individual. what makes the
individual happy and what kind of says
is that's stupid. You have to focus on
what makes a community happy because
it's only through food happiness of
others can we ourselves be happy. Okay,
this is something that Jesus said
Zorusta Dante. Okay, this is what makes
logical sense and Mars is not a dumb
guy. Okay, he's a really smart person
but he says something opposite which
suggests to us that he is being
influenced by an outside force. Okay. He
himself would not come to the conclusion
that
he himself would not come to the
conclusion that you need a vanguard to
lead the uh the workers.
All right. Can you keep on reading?
Amber
>> available to everyone will be a general
scientific education especially the
learning of the scientific method, the
habit of correct thinking, the ability
to generalize from facts and make more
or less correct deductions. But of
encyclopedic minds and advanced so
sociologists there will be very few. It
would be sad for mankind if at any time
theoretical speculation became the only
source of guidance for society. If
science alone were in charge of all
social administration. Life would wither
and human society would turn into a
voiceless and surv. The domination of
life by science can have no other result
than the brutalization of mankind. Okay.
So what he's saying is this the ultimate
project of Marxism when you have
something elite a vanguard in charge
when this is no different by the way
from trans national capital or the
British Empire okay it would lead to
slavery
all right and quite honestly he was
right
all right let's look at Simon Freud okay
Sigman Freud like Marx is also extremely
influential
um He practiced medicine in Vienna. He
was a psychologist. And so there were a
lot of young women who came to him as
patients. And for would ask them,
"What's wrong with you?" And the woman
would say, "I'm hysterical." Okay? And
at that time, hysterical just meant that
um depressed or anxious. I can't control
my emotions. If a man talks to me, I
like I I I stutter and I I I run away.
Okay? And I can't have personal
relationships. I can't sleep. I'm
sweating. I'm anxious. And then for of
course would ask him would ask them why
is this happening to you to you? Okay.
And then the woman would say because
when I was younger when I was a little
girl my father raped me. Okay. Incest.
That's why this happened to me. And then
Freud's like, "Wow, this sounds really
strange." But then he looked at at the
literature. He talked to many patients
and he recognized that everyone was
telling him the same thing. And it's
true. I mean it's just pure um logic
right if you are abused as a young girl
by your father you have a lot of social
problems when you get older okay
especially with men and so he he
collects all this research and he
published a paper which is very good
called the ideology of hysteria and so
uh Emma can you can you read please
>> above all my previously communicated
assumption that trauma specifically
sexual trauma cannot be stressed of as a
path a p pathogenic agent was confirmed
a new even children of respected
high-minded puritanical families fall
victim to real rape much more frequently
than other had dared to suspect
>> okay so this is what he's saying is this
rape is a really common phenomenon
especially among higher society okay
keep on going
>> either their parents themselves seek
substitution for their lack of sexual
satisfaction in this pathological manner
or else trusted persons such as
relatives, uncles, aunts, grandparents,
tutors, servants, abuse, ignorance and
innocence of children. The obvious
objection that we are dealing with
sexual fantasies of the of the child
himself that is with historical lies
unfortunately is weakened by the
multitude of confessions of this kind on
the part of patients in analysis to
assaults on children.
>> Okay. So what he's saying is first of
all rape is very common and these
children are saying the same thing.
Okay, keep on going.
>> If you try in a uh an approximately
similar way to induce the symptoms of
hysteria to make themselves heard as
witnesses to the history of the origin
of the illness, we must take our start
from Joseph Brewer's momentous
discovery. The symptoms of hysteria
apart from the stigmata are determined
by certain experiences of the patients
which have operated in a traumatic
fashion and which are being rep
reproduced in his uh psych psychical
psychical life in the form of mimic
symbols.
>> Okay. So this is the ideas are simple.
Okay. These women when they're being
historical, when they're being anxious,
depressed, it's because they suffered
real trauma when they were younger,
they're not making this up, okay?
They're not imagining this because a lot
of people are accusing them like you're
just fantasizing this. Okay? And they
say, "No, no, no. The science tells us,
the research tells us you can only have
these symptoms if you yourself
experience it." Okay? You cannot imagine
a leg injury. It has you have to be hit
by a car to have a leg injury. And and
this is what he's saying. You have to be
raped by your father or a trusted friend
or a relative in order to have these
symptoms. Otherwise, they can't exist.
Okay. All right. Keep on going.
All right. So, this is a book by Jeffrey
Mason. Okay. And and he was for the
longest time an um follower of Freud.
Okay.
um Freud was dead but he himself looked
at Freud's personal letters and what he
discovered was there's a sharp break
okay and early Freud was very scientific
he believed the woman uh who are his
patients but then later on for a reason
he changes everything okay so so so can
can you keep on reading Amber
>> I therefore put forward the thesis that
at the bottom of every case wisteria
there are one or more occurrences of
premature sexual experience occurrences
which belong to the earliest years of
childhood but which can be reproduced
through the work of psychoanalysis in
spite of the intervening decades
>> okay so again he's writing these letters
to his friends and he's saying very
clearly I am certain 100% certain that
if these women are suffering from
depression or anxiety it must be because
of sexual abuse at an earlier age and
when I talk to them I can reconstruct
the experience. Okay? Because even
though they're traumatized, the memory
is still there. So through talk therapy,
I can slowly reconstruct the experience
and this will help them heal. Okay? And
this is true. If the if the women are
able to reconstruct this experience and
they feel as though someone believes
them, advocates for them, they will feel
much more safe about the world. Okay? So
this is true. This is very simple. Okay?
Keep on going. There are however a whole
number of other things that vouch for
the reality of infantile sexual scenes.
In the first place there is the
uniformity which they exhibit in certain
details which is a necessary consequence
if the preconditions of these
experiences are always of the same kind
but which would otherwise lead us to
believe that there were secret
understandings between the various
patients.
>> Okay. So, what he's saying is, is it
possible there's conspiracy among these
patients?
Um, possibly. But they're telling me
they're giving me like these details and
these details make a lot of sense. Okay?
So, he doesn't believe it's a
conspiracy, but he does not discount the
possibility of a conspiracy because he's
a scientist. He wants to be rigorous. He
wants to be um absolutely certain. Okay?
Keep on going. In the second place,
patients sometimes describe as harmless
events whose significance they obviously
do not understand since they would be
bound otherwise to be horrified by them
or again they mention details without
laying any stress on them which only
someone of experience in life can
understand and appreciate as subtle
traits of reality.
>> Okay. So he he says that one thing about
this trauma is this disassociation.
Okay. So these patients will reveal
details that would shock anyone else but
she says it indifferently which means
that she was disassociated from the
experience when it happened. So just by
telling that person you're able to
reconstruct the experience itself.
Right? Does that make sense? All right.
Okay.
It is less easy to refute the idea that
the doctor forces a reminiscence of this
word on the patient that he influences
him by suggestion to imagine and
reproduce them. Nevertheless, it appears
to me equally untenable. I have never
yet succeeded in forcing on a patient a
scene I was expecting to find in such a
way that he seemed to be living through
it with all the appropriate feelings.
Perhaps other may be more successful in
this. So one major objection is is it
possible you are you are implanting
false memories in your patient and what
he's saying is okay well I've tried this
and it doesn't work and maybe others and
he he doesn't deny that it's possible
okay but he's saying like I myself have
tried this and it has not worked so he's
being a very rigorous scientist right
he's looking at all different
possibilities and he's discovering that
no um there's only one possibility which
is like they are telling the truth. So
he's advocating for his patients. Okay.
The problem though of course is that the
fathers who are doing this are extremely
powerful men. These are Frank. Okay.
Remember Frankus practice
um
uh father daughter incest. Okay.
Understand? Okay. that Franks are very
powerful people especially in Vienna
and this is part of their religion. If
you do it over generations, it just
becomes multigenerational trauma. You
just do it because it's you're addicted
to it. Okay. And this is screwing up a
lot of these young women. It's making
them miserable. Uh yeah.
Uh so you mentioned that this kind of
rape is frequently occurred in upper
class. Why does it not so frequently in
the lower class?
>> Um, you know what? That's a good
question. Okay. And the answer is,
um, if you are an upper class woman,
you're much more likely to report this
than if you are from the lower class.
So, I'm not we're not saying that this
occurs only among the rich. It could
also occur among the poor. But it's the
rich who have money to send their
daughters to psych psych to
psychiatrists. Okay? The rich are
educated and therefore they will report
this. They understand this is a bad
thing. Okay. So we don't have evidence
to suggest that this is more common
among rich. Okay. But what this is
telling us is that among Frank is this
is very common.
All right.
All right. So after this happens after
Freud is reporting this and the Frankus
are getting angry at him. What happens
now is an alliance between Freud and the
Frankus. In fact, you could argue that
Freud now joins a fractus. And so now
what we'll see is a radical change
in how Freud perceives these patients.
Okay. So, Emma, can you read please?
>> Since childhood masturbation is such a
general occurrence and is at the same
time so poorly remembered, it must have
an equivalent in psychic life. And in
fact, it is found in the fantasy
encountered in most female patients.
>> Okay. namely that
>> namely that the father seduced her in
childhood. This is the later reworking
which is designed to cover up the
recollection of infantile sexual
activity and represents an excuse and an
extinuation thereof. The grain of truth
contained in this fantasy lies in the
fact that the father by way of his
innocent car caress in earliest
childhood has actually
awakened the little girl's sexuality.
The same thing applies to the little boy
and his mother. It is these same
affectionate fathers that are the ones
who then endeavored to break the child
of the habit of masturbation of which
they themselves had by the that time
become the unwitting cause and thus the
motives mingle in the most successful
fashion to form this fantasy which often
dominates a woman's entire life.
seduction fantasy. One part truth, one
part gratification of love, and one part
revenge.
>> Okay, so now this is like really weird.
Okay, what what he's saying is these
young girls, these young boys, they want
to have sex. They they're they're like
sexually obsessed. And whenever a father
kisses them, which the father wants to
do, they think this is this is going to
lead to sex. But the father recoils at
that possibility. And now the young girl
feels rejected. But she has all these
sexual desires. So she masturbates, but
while she's masturbating, she feels
anger and guilt at her father.
Therefore, she makes up these sexual
fantasies that the father is raping him.
And that's why and she's determined that
the world know this. That's that's how
angry he she is at him. Okay, this is
complete nonsense. But guess what guys?
This becomes standard mainstream
academic knowledge taught in schools and
universities for many decades. Okay,
this is called the edifo complex. That's
that's a complex. Have you guys studied
this?
>> Yeah.
>> It's complete utter nonsense.
>> Agree.
>> Right.
Can you keep on reading, Amber? The
motives.
>> The motives for illness often begin to
stir in childhood. The love hungry
little girl unhappy at having to share
her parents' affection with her brothers
and sisters, realizes that all that
tenderness comes flowing back when her
parents are made anxious by her illness.
The girl now knows a way of calling
forth her parents' love and will use
this as soon as as she has at her
disposal the psychical psychical
material necessary to produce a morbid
state. Once the child has become a woman
and in contradiction of the demands of
the childhood has married an inattentive
man who suppresses her will unst uh
unstintingly exploits her work and
expends neither affection nor money upon
her. Illness becomes the only weapon
with which she can assert herself in
life. It gives her the it gives her the
rest she craves. It force it forces the
man to make uh to make sacrifices of
money and care that he would not have
made to the wealthy woman uh to the
healthy woman and it requires him to
treat her with care if she recovers
because otherwise a relapse would be
waiting in the wings. Her illness is
apparently objective and involuntary as
even her doctor will be obliged to
testify and it enables her to employ
without conscious self-reroach. this
useful application of a means that she
found effective during childhood.
>> So why is woman being hysterical later
in life? Because it allows them to
control people. Okay, it it draws
attention to them. They want attention
but also makes people obey her whims.
Okay, this is gaslighting. All right,
this is peer and other gaslighting. And
the guys, this is what psychology is
just peer and other gaslighting. Okay.
All right. Um the problem of course is
how do you convince your patient that
this is true and so he develops a mind
control technique called dream analysis.
Okay this is his book from the book
interp interpretation of dreams. Okay
and it's all just mind control crap
where the patient is trying to recall
dreams and you're brainwashing that
patient. Okay? Because if you've
discussed memory that that the person
like I know what I saw, right? But his
dreams then you can implant false
memories. Then you can make suggestions.
You can hypnotize that person. Okay? And
so psychology becomes now mind control.
Okay. So can you read? [snorts] I think
everyone who occupies himself with
dreams will recognize as a very common
phenomenon that fact that a the fact
that a dream will give proof of the
knowledge and a recollection of matters
of which the dreamer in his waking state
did not imagine himself to be cog
cognizant cognizant in my analytic
investigations of the nervous patients
of which I shall speak later. I find
that it happens many times every week
that I am able to convince them from
their dreams that they are perfectly
well acquainted with quotations, obscene
expressions, etc.
>> Okay? So, do you understand? So, when
when the person is talking about his
dream, you can now make suggestions and
that person will believe whatever crap
you tell him. Okay? And that's a secret
of mind control. And guess what, guys?
We still use this crap today. All right?
All right. So um Floyd is of course
gaslighting everyone because he has to
protect his patrons the Frankus and the
Frankus will allow him to get very will
become very famous. He'll get a lot of
awards. When the Nazis come to power
they he'll go to England where he's well
treated. He joins the Royal Academy. Um
the British protect him and the British
will then spread his views. Okay. He has
a uh disciple Carl Young who will take
his for ideas and turn it into a
understanding a systematic understanding
of how the mind works and from this will
develop neuroscience. Okay. Um the
problem with all this this is public
problem with all this is asan tells us
it's all selfdirected inwards which
gives us nowhere. Okay. It's just you
looking into yourself. It's naval gazing
and from that you learn no truth at all.
But that's the entire basis of our
society.
And so
um so yeah so this is so our so this um
understanding of the mind becomes
reflected in popular culture. Okay.
U back to Macan he tells us that to be
truly free we all have to be free. We
have to be free together. Okay. In each
other we find meaning, purpose and love.
Okay. Not in oursel but in each other.
That's a difference. And so this leads
us to a question. Okay. And this is a
question I don't know this today. It's
all speculation. The question I want to
leave with with you today is is Marxism,
liberalism, individualism, Darwinism,
psychology ops meant to turn us into
slaves? Okay, that's a question that you
have to carry with you. I don't know the
answer to I don't know the answer to to
that. Okay, I'm just providing you with
a theory and these connections we don't
know how close they are. Okay, it may it
may not it may just be random
coincidence. It could be cause and
effect. We don't know. Okay, but this
something that you will have to ask
yourself as you continue your study.
Okay, so this shows us in alliance
between the Sabatine Franks and the
British Empire. And so next class will
be our last class and in our last class
we'll talk about the past Judea. Okay,
which is a culmination of all these
trends. All right, any questions, guys?
Okay, great. So, I will see everyone
next class.